au canada la saint valentin la fête des
amoureux devient de plus en plus la fête
des célibataires qui ne veulent plus
l'être et tous les moyens vous allez le
voir sont bons un site internet a
organisé un concours de poésie il ya
quelques semaines
objectif gagner sa propre campagne de
pub par affichage pour trouver l'âme
soeur estelle colin carole gréco lesmont
à toucher ton visage et a embrassé
l'amour qui emporte comme un ouragan
c'est avec ces quelques mots d'amour
qu'il a gagné qu'il a gagné ça sauve
visage placardée dans tout paris
bref jean michel sala faire du mois
c'est surtout une façon amusante de se
mettre sur le marché des célibataires et
de se mettre en avant
jean michel est célibataire comme 8
millions de français
et comme nabil à l'autre gagnante du
concours les doigts sur le clavier nous
caressons nos nuits
tu fais vivre mon âme ra dix mois cela
mme jetté tant rêver au bout du virtuel
toi mon amour bien réel j'ai envie de
thé mais pour l'éternité
sa requête amoureuse a dit les murs
parisiens pas moins de 100 panneaux
publicitaires une campagne d'une valeur
de 15 mille euros avec à la clé
peut-être le grand amour
au départ c'était super difficile de
faire une déclaration d'amour sans avoir
d'amoureux donc me suis inspiré je me
suis inspiré
de mon fils dont qui m'a permis d'aller
jusqu'au bout de la déclaration d'amour
en tout cas pour jean michel comme pour
nabila cela pourrait payer car les
français ont une particularité on
compare avec les autres pays où on a
également des célibataires on s'aperçoit
que si les français sont très nous
sommes très romantique les français deux
fois plus que les autres européens nous
disent qu'ils sont capables de tomber
amoureux seraient pas s'échangeant des
emails et en ce jour de la saint
valentin
internet sert non seulement à trouver
l'amour mais aussi à l'entretenir sur
les écrans numériques de paris des
milliers de messages des cultes depuis
ce matin on y apprend que françoise est
amoureuse que stéphanie adore fabrice et
christophe ferait mieux de rappeler
catherine sylvia l'homme qu'il prétend
être